welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Michael Keaton may once again
whisper into our collective face I'm
Batman with reports that Keaton will
reprise his Bruce Wayne from the Tim
Burton Batman films in the upcoming Ezra
Miller flash movie as a multiverse elder
mentor figure kind of like Nick Fury in
the MCU which is not at all confusing
after Keaton seems to be just wandering
from the MCU as the vulture into the
spume coos pumpka
with the hunka hunka Jared Leto in
Morbius the living vampire all wild
quoting the Space Jam Cinematic Universe
what's up Keaton well combined with
other rumors that Jeffrey Dean Morgan
could return it's Thomas Wayne in this
flashpoint storyline and the little
trailer we just got for the upcoming
Snyder cut of Justice League coming next
year on HBO max there are just a lot of
questions about which parts of the DC
movie universe will connect and which
are just figments of art reflects
imagination yeah that's life okay so
this is all coming together in the
upcoming film of the flash which is
currently in pre-production and had its
release date moved up from July 2022 to
June 3rd 2022 it and it's chapter 2
director Andy machete is directing and
Ezra Miller is starring as Barry Allen
returning from Justice League and his
recent crossover cameo in the crisis on
Infinite Earths event on the CW series
actually if you watch that you may have
noticed that it was shot in a different
aspect ratio with deeper color grading
as if they had jumped from the TV side
of the universe to a cinematic one could
be a clue that Barry's cameo there may
be part of a wider story on film maybe
even a scene in this flash movie crisis
on Infinite Earths also opened with a
cameo by the reporter from the Keaton
Batman connected and less Yeti confirmed
that they are pulling story elements
from the flashpoint comic storyline that
was the major 2011 flash crossover event
it was amazing DC Comics used it to
reestablish its new 52 universe
flashpoint Barry Allen uses the Speed
Force to ruin real fast back in time to
save his mother but as is always the
case and do it so the timelines just get
all out of whack with various alternate
universes converging this flash movie
appears to be using that conceit as the
basis for
DC Multiverse time in past film
universes as they did in crisis on
Infinite Earths with the center of that
madness being Ezra Miller Barry Allen
the flash with Michael Keaton Bruce
wayne/batman
an aged mentor who I'm guess it still
packs a punch maybe similar to the
elderly Bruce Wayne we saw in Batman
Beyond in the way that series used the
voice of animated Batman Kevin Conroy
voice in my childhood and his
no-nonsense grizzle as they foiled to
the young Terry McKenna's deal with it
was perfect and this partnership between
Keaton and Miller seems like the same
kind of relationship to me so by the way
I won't be complaining of Conroy cameos
in a slasher movie as he did in the
crisis event you know can we just of all
the Batman's please so let's go to the
details how will the flash connect to
all of the DC Universe the truth is
kinda hard to know at this point just
like it's hard to know whether someone's
carrying the most discreet front pocket
wallet the ridge thanks to the ridge for
sponsoring this episode
the ridge helps you carry what you need
every day from their flagship Ridge
wallet to their portable charging
commuter backpack they want to make the
most out of what you're bringing with
you the ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
and carbon fiber has a clean stylish
design and it's a chain saw proof a
Batman could use this for his armor he'd
be fine well you'd be flying against a
rogue's gallery villain who like uses
chain saws this is their black titanium
wallet but they do have other colors
including some very flashy Tiki designs
it's light and it's strong just like
your soul and they make it easy to buy
with free shipping and free returns and
a lifetime guarantee
it's got 30,000 five-star reviews so you
know they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with RFID blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries get
10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars that's Ridge
comm slash new rock stars and use the
code new rock stars find the link in the
video's description okay while the flash
movie with Keaton expands the DC
Multiverse using the flashpoint paradox
don't count on this being the future of
DC cinematic as a whole that reads
Robert Pattinson the Batman coming in
October 2021 is planned to be the focal
title for DC movies going forward and
while there are some rumors about that
being a trilogy launching a new Joker
maybe it doesn't sound like it'll
crossover with this flash movie or any
elements of the old DCE
but rather be a standalone reset similar
to the Joaquin Phoenix Joker film which
was also kind of an else world reset
right really it gave DC in the studio
the financial and award success that
they are definitely now aiming for in
future films but flashpoint looks like
their fun side adventure where they
continue to try to connect everything
and confusing but awesome fanservice see
ways like Marvel does now as we saw in
the recent teaser with Darkseid awesome
Zack Snyder's Justice League series is
coming to HBO max in 2021 and in that we
will probably see some removed sequences
that set up the flash movie for example
one of Snyder's subplots would have seen
Barry Allen flash and Victor stones
cyborg tinkering with tech and the Speed
Force in order to go back in time to
Bruce Wayne's time vortex vision a
Batman V Superman to warn him about dart
Clark now Lois is the key and it has
been confirmed that cyborg will join
Barry Allen in the flash movie so this
new Schneider cut sequence could serve
as a kind of prologue for a flashpoint
paradox scenario that sets up the crisis
of the flash movie the following year
now besides Michael Keaton we've also
seen reports that Jeffrey Dean Morgan
could reprise his role as Thomas Wayne
from the flashback scene and Batman V
Superman
and this is super exciting because in
flashpoint one of the alternate
timelines that Barry Allen converges
with is a kind of darkest timeline in
which Joe Chill killed Bruce Wayne
instead leading to Thomas Wayne becoming
Batman and Martha Wayne becoming that
timelines version of the Joker
after Geoffrey de Morgan's role is the
violent vigilante the comedian and Zack
Snyder's Watchmen movie and the morally
clouded psychopath negan on the walking
dead a vengeful Thomas Wayne Batman
tussling with Barry Allen and Michael
Keaton Batman yet that's my head Canon
come into life there have also been some
other reports that Henry Cavill might be
a toxin return to Superman in a future
DC movie Beyond Justice League I have
long doubted that he would star in any
Man of Steel to film especially after
talks broke down between him and the
studio during the Justice League
reshoots
it's just a matter of like a simple
favor to andy machete to cameo in his
flashpoint movie and emotion yet he lets
them keep as much fur on that basis he
once
Capel steam could also show up on this
bonkers Call Sheet but that does leave
poor poor Bette flick who sadly may have
to see Snyder's Justice League as his
final time in the cow
just because it's hard for me to see the
studio wanting the most recent version
of Bruce back in the cowl after they
rebooted the character eight months
earlier but hopefully we do get some
kind of cameo just to give us that
closure especially if they adapt the
moment from the end of flashpoint when
the flash delivers Thomas Waynes letter
to the main universe Batman to give him
and all of us some heartbreaking closure
maybe even this handed off letter could
be written by Martha Wayne who in Batman
V Superman was played by Morgan's
walking dead co-star lauren cohan seen
ben affleck read a letter signed by
martha hey it could be a really nice way
to fix one of the more controversial
elements from Snyder's Canon and bring
it home in a way that makes us feel bad
for ever mocking it for me what actors
and characters from past DC films would
you like to see cameo in this flash
movie along with Michael Keaton in
jeopardy Morgan Danny DeVito at the
penguin Jim Carrey is a Riddler Ryan
Reynolds is Hal Jordan actually we're
gonna dive into this question on a
segment and rogue theory this week be
sure to check it out and you can talk
about this stuff directly with us in new
rockstars official discord community
which you can get exclusive access to by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rockstars follow me on instagram at
EA vas follow new rockstars on social
and subscribe to this channel for
breakdowns of everything you love thank
you for watching the video and thanks
for watching over all of us Batman
[Music]